now police say two suspects are still at
large in the province of saskatchewan in
canada they're believed to have killed
10 people in a series of knife attacks
and wounded at least 15 others
let's speak now to the leader of the
saskatchewan new democratic party carla
beck thank you very much for being with
us and i mean this is just the most
awful atrocity
it really is um we woke up again this
morning to news that the suspects are
still at large
and we really do have a province right
now that is that is grieving that is
looking for answers
and um you know looking to support those
who've been so horribly impacted by the
senseless senseless act
indeed i mean do you know any more about
who
has done this
well
very early yesterday two suspects were
identified
there were a number of public
alerts that went out and alerted the
public to be on the lookout for these
two individuals
we got an update from law enforcement
this morning that despite efforts
overnight to locate these two
individuals
we still do not know uh their their
location
and there have been alerts that have
been issued for not only saskatchewan
but neighboring provinces as well i
don't think that we know a lot about
them and and certainly not motivation
but we do know that the acts that were
inflicted yesterday morning have le had
just a devastating impact on our
province
absolutely and you just hinted there
about a motive i mean
is there any
idea why something like this could have
happened
well i think at this point we just know
that this is um appears to be a
senseless
attack
there
the law enforcement officers have noted
that some of the victims may have been
known
to the suspects but others seem to be
just random
acts of violence um you know this is
we're talking about the james smith cree
nation um where
most of the fatalities and
stabbings occurred as a community of
just over 1500 people the nearby town of
weldon is a small village of 200.
you know this is just devastating
devastating news to
wake up to devastating violence and in
our heart just goes out to those
communities the leaders
the first responders and of course those
who are treating the wounded right now
in our province
absolutely
just tell us if you can carla a little
more about this indigenous community
well this is a james smith cree nation
um in the north uh central um central
eastern part of the province
a community with an on
on reserve
population of about 1500 a number of
band members who who live off reserve
you know a very
small community
i did have opportunity to speak with the
chief this morning of course in a
community that small
any community this is a devastating
tragedy but a community that small where
everyone knows everyone i can only
imagine the pain and the horror that not
only the chief is going through but but
the whole community and our hearts
really do go out to them
absolutely and i'm just reading here
that the police are dealing with 13
different crime scenes
yeah this is what's been reported 13
different crime scenes across at least
two different
different communities again
very small communities our province and
and some of your listeners uh you know
maybe hearing about saskatchewan for the
first time um you know in the center of
canada where a million people on a land
mass
largely equivalent to ukraine so
you know sparsely populated tight-knit
communities and this really
has been has been devastating we we're
not sure where again those suspects are
this morning i think that there was a
lot of heartache and a lot of sleepless
nights in our province last night as we
we wait to hear more details and
hopefully have a peaceful as possible
resolution to this tragedy absolutely
absolutely a dreadful incident karla
beck thank you very much for being with
us thank you
thank you so much